ladies and gentlemen we have to start
now this we talked about pass now excuse
me now we will talk about future we have
not enough time no for Europe yeah but I
hope we have a good discussion and
though it was mentioned that it is you
know much easier on the neutral ground
to discuss such as complicated relation
a German Polish relation but probably
the same is with europe united Europe
sometimes in europe i have an impression
you cannot really you know be skeptical
a bit about your integration yes
sometimes this like blasphemy to talk to
pull some problems and I hope that we
will also talk not also about you know
advantages of this integration but maybe
also about these differences of
perspective on Europe what may be rooted
in the historic experience we are very
distinguished panelist the first one is
my magic jihad scheme who is a political
philosopher and public intellectual very
known in Poland connected with many
institution I really don't remember one
is University of Warsaw but the other is
the center of European studies and
nurturing and and he published many
books one of Europe and German German
Polish relation are one very important
chapter of this book one book about
conservatism and today he's a adviser to
polish president for the question of
European treaty in Germany also very
known as the Dutchman creature Dinka yes
was mentioned by one man in my journal
so we will see what is your perspective
and what is the power polish position in
this respect as a respect of the of the
UN treaty the next panelist enhance your
guns answered I now I know that you were
born in India what was unexpectedly yeah
but many also very educated in New York
partly and since many years in German
Foreign Office in Moscow in Mogadishu
and then Mauch from Mogadishu you move
to also in Brazil in between iya and
then they also mr. Himes observed as a
private secretary of federal president
erika von weizsäcker and now is a consul
general in USA and we have also polished
as a council of general of polish
republic in New York mr. chest of
kasprzyk who is this is certain since
many years in also in the service of the
Polish diplomatic service in his plan
for office 16 years but before he was he
was doing than you know in physics what
what is very nature science what is
yeah sometimes disturb you know from the
science to the to the diplomacy may be
an advantage you know to to apply the
criteria of the strong rationality to
the topic of history and politics and
the deceptive which is our next speaker
spoke last email and who is professor of
political science at University in 30
but since several years he is a director
of the German and Historical Institute
in Warsaw before he was now I was
mentioned as dead the only professor of
political science in Germany who knew
something about Paul so many he has many
many really many PhDs and and the
youngest color world were made other his
written under his supervision and now
he's also my colleague from the
University of Cardinal stefan wyszynski
in walls of the cell the same department
so we start with mark jihad ski please
maybe short shorter than than previously
maybe 15 minutes strong Jesus and turn
yeah and then we had a probably more
time for discussion please thank you
very much mr. channel
mr. Himes that is offered me a cup of
coffee so I have to limit my criticism
during my presentation but first first
of all I would like to stressed it and
mostly interested in in the polish
German relations not in the polish
German reconciliation because paradox
Lee it seems to me that it was easier to
to complete this idea of reconciliation
then to establish a real partnership
real political relations between Poland
and and German I think that was a
bristle krasnodar skehoe who said thank
you this is jeff is assured this is a
sign of good polish general polish
relations thank you for everything and
reconciliation and in that sense what
what what would president is he said
some some some weeks ago I think during
this this conference and also we are
reconciliate and and it's not the main
problem in the polish German relations
we are reconciliate and now we have to
open up a new chapter and which means to
be able to discuss
different problems different issues each
in its own Manya and to communicate it
and to try to to understand it so first
of all the polish German relations are
important not only because of Poland and
Germany but sir and that it's my second
point because of off of Europe because
of the European Union it seems to me
that this relations are now desire z
4444 future of Europe I know it very
well that not all are aware in Germany
and also in Poland of the importance of
this relations for the future shape of
of of Europe but it seems to me that
without without opening this new chapter
opening up this new chapter in our
relation it is not possible to use this
this political opportunity given us by
the by the enlargement because that
largement to me is not the end of the
whole story but it's just the beginning
of the whole story and this is maybe the
main difference between my point of view
and and and and this older generation in
Poland which which was so strongly
involved in the reconciliation the
polish German reconciliation and also in
the in the process of the of the
of the enlargement what doesn't mean
that this this this this just the
beginning of the of the whole of the
whole story I think that there are three
issues which which which which are in my
opinion important for for for for
understanding to the the meaning of of
the polish German relations for the
European Union are and for the Europe as
decimal in in future then despite offer
of an issue which is related to the
European identity policy and it which
was discussed in the previous
discussions today it seems to me that
the one important point is the question
of the uncertainty of the further
development of off of Russia and the
political situation in Russia and this
issue treats touched polished German
relations directly so far I know
Vladimir Putin is interested first of
all in the situation in Poland and in
Germany from the from the from the
European countries he he is provided by
a very deep
and comprehensive information every day
regarding this two countries is to
European countries poland and germany
and i think this is a good reason why
it's it's so because i think that these
two countries are from also from the
Russian point of view to Europe this
these two countries are decisive and the
situation in this two countries are
decisive also for the you European
policy of off of Russia the second issue
is the problem of the leadership in
Europe this will be the most difficult
problem to me because of this cup of
coffee and the first issue is is is that
is the is the future of the
transatlantic community which is also
decisive 444 polish to German German
relations and now my first point Russia
that point was also discussed so I I
will only point out this elements which
which are important according to my
assessment first of all energy security
and energy policy and this is a this is
a challenge it is Poland and Germany
able to to cooperate
in this energy policy and my answer is
so far the previous policy is
consumption I'm rather pessimistic and
of course it's not that pipeline project
is is something which determines our our
our our situation now and our approach
to this to this problem in Poland but
also in in Germany in Germany this is
the problem of the industry which is
very strong involved in this project and
is very influential in the political
sphere and this is a project of the some
parts I wouldn't say the whole of course
but this is a problem of course of some
parts of SPD and the way in which this
political party would like to to pursue
the policy toward Russia in in in in
future the second problem related to
this Russian issue is is the stability
of the post-soviet region and this is
the question not only of the relations
between the European Union and enter
hacia but Sir Germany perceive Russia as
a partner in stabilization stabilization
to the whole a post-soviet area and my
problem is have we have we really the
same approach we Europeans and the
Russians to this to this ridge of course
my answer is no this approach is is
quite different and what we have to
clarify
with with Germany is what we really
understand understand in details under
this notion the European neighbourhood
policy I I know that it was such idea
launched by by Germans at the end of the
last year this this project of en P plus
then it was suddenly stopped and so my
impression is now that but maybe I am I
am I am rock depth that the German
policy preferred to prove to do a
contract with Russian partners in
creation of the of the European
neighbourhood policy den for example
with the Polish partners but as I said
maybe my assessment is it's not so it's
not correct and the firts a problem
regarding this Russian issue is the
question of the consolidation of the
Central Europe with the West Europe
within the European Union and this is
the whole this is not only this whole
story with meat and to embargo this is
also the problem of Baltic States energy
policy and this is the question the what
extent for example Germany as the moon
maybe most important country in the
European Union politically and and and
and economically to what extent is
Germany ready to to be involved in
consolidating this part of Europe within
the European Union which which which
place of course germany in in a conflict
with
with Russian interests for example it's
Germany ready to risk such a conflict
but in favor of consolidating to the
European Union or not and my conclusion
to this part of my presentation would be
I I think that what we need is ready an
Eastern policy but i think that faced
with this dis questions and with this
with this need of clarification what is
the german position what is the polish
position this Eastern policy which
naturally help us very much in
consolidating this this eastern eastern
policy at this stage maybe in future it
will be easier but now I don't don't
believe in it the second point is the
leadership in in Europe so maybe I will
take first gen dis coffee and then
continue I think I was attendant I was
attendance this 17 anniversary of the
wrong treaties
in the lane and something was clear to
me a miracle is not a call in political
sense of course it is not true that
Marco continue the policy the European
policy of of Helmut Kohl why not because
Helmut Kohl in my assessment he he tried
to do to keep the balance between
Germany and other European countries
small or big but with all these
countries before the unification and she
tried to do it even after the
unification and maybe it was there isn't
what why he failed in the elections with
with with with with shredder Merkel is
ready to lead in my in my opinion she is
ready to to play this role of the
political leadership in in the European
in the European Union and the situation
is it's very helpful to fulfill this
this this project of the of the
leadership and because united kingdom is
as usual not very much interested in
European affairs and will be even less
interested in in future if we can
foresee the political development in the
in there in the United Kingdom France of
course everyone expected
the outcome of the elections in France
but I think it doesn't count in that
sense that that that France will be
devoted to do it splendid protection
aliza latian in in future and will be
not very much interested in European
affairs also so I think that this is a
free space for for for for Germany to
play this this role of the of the leader
in the European Union but I am afraid
that despite of the fact that maybe
Germany is prepared and ready to play
such a role of the leadership in the in
the European Union I am rather
pessimistic whether the European Union
is ready to to accept such leadership in
that sense I think that we are back to
this fundamental question posed by
Timothy Garton are in this book you have
mentioned previously in name of Europe
we are back to the to the question what
is the future is the future to European
Germany or German Europe but of course
the situation is much more complex
because we have done largement and this
is even more difficult to have a good
answer to this fundamental question in
anat lab in an inland European Union the
last point is the transatlantic
transatlantic a community I think that
we should avoid something we we are
faced with now namely some kind of
rivalry between Poland and and and and
Germany who is the better friend of of
you night
United States in Europe this is
something of course comment to this
question of the political leadership in
the European Union because of course not
only Russia is interested to have a
European leader also united states are
interested in having a European leader a
country which will lead Europe and which
the United States can contact with to
deal the European problems not with all
this small countries czech republic
belgium and so complicated so it's much
more simple to have a one partner which
is responsible for the whole european
union and which act in name of of of of
of europe so i think that if we take for
example the whole discussion on the on
the missile defense system between
Poland and Germany of course there is
there is also a problem of the security
of Europe and of dividing Europe but but
to some extent the answer is this this
rivalry between Poland and and and and
and Germany who is better in keeping
European interest vasavi united united
states which is of course a very
important question when we consider the
fact that the Americans are less and
less interested in Europe of course and
this is what what makes people in Europe
pregnant that that America will lost the
interest on
europe at all and finally the conclusion
i think that first of all and john
polish relations are decisive in my
opinion folder future say both of europe
and european union then we have the
problem of of russia which is the polish
german problem in fact and then we have
the problem of their political
leadership in the european union it
seems me it is also a polish german
problem also if we take the particular
case of the constitutional treaty at the
end poland and germany s is at the stage
and have to tackle the whole problem if
not then we will not have any
constitutional treaty and first the
problem of the transatlantic community
with which is also very strongly a
german polish problem generally speaking
i think that maybe the polities a shin
of the european union is unavoidable
process but in my assessment this is
this is this is a long-term process and
first of all we have to clarify our
national positions within of course
european union between mostly between
Poland and and and and and and Germany
because we have to we have to we have to
we have to make a progress because of of
of the lost time in in in the past and
then maybe we can build any political
a project in in in in in Europe thank
you very much two diplomats in fallon
promised to blow mattox i first have to
admit that in 10 years in university I
think I never was an auditorium at 5 45
on the sunny spring day so seeing all of
you here I must say you all must be
athletes una dos and to the s of the
german-polish relations german-polish
reconciliation so I feel absolutely at
the right spot to be together with you
and I have to say to other things yes I
openness I'll try to be long diplomatic
i am not dealing with german polish
relations in my function which I copy
occupy today and in New York so I'll try
to be open and please forgive it and a
second I didn't have the long flight
from Warsaw from Berlin so I didn't
prepare a long manuscript and just speak
freely but don't rejoice because people
speaking was manuscripts always be
shorter before coming to the question
put on the European institutions let me
say a few words on the bilateral
relations linking up two points made
yesterday evening there was this nice
picture of Germany and Poland both
looking west and Germany in that way
showing polish Poland its back it's true
but it's also not true
not true anymore the way it has been of
course still Germans look also to the
west i would say i would take your word
of Protagoras there has been a blue
realization but when I see even today
here in New York young people's interns
the consulate they have spent half here
in Warsaw and so on there's so many
students now attracted to go to Poland
and I would say there is a big number of
German turns interested in Poland
probably more than from a lot of other
European countries there was also the
point made yes 600 school partnerships
yes but met Franz you have two thousand
and so well it's always a question a
glass half full glass half empty but if
you know that we have 700 school
partnerships with the United States
Poland being a country more than three
times smaller United States you're at
that level so it always depends on the
perspective and even it's four times
more than we have was great britain so I
would say what has been done in German
Polish relations from 1990 to 2000 is
incredible and should not be
underestimated but used this comparison
with France you know that German
politicians around the year 2000 always
used to say we want German Polish
relations come to the level of German
French relations I don't think they are
still saying it why not because it's a
question of how you take this questioner
German German French Country
conciliation was not a bottom-up process
it didn't come out of the heart of the
Germans or the fridge it was a top-down
process by the government's it was
political will which made it happen and
it was one institution we created this
was a Dodge consider you back at the
youth exchange program mainly we have so
many more German Polish Air Nations than
the organization than was any other
country in the world the we have so many
foundations we have prizes we can't name
them yes more than was any other country
of the world and I would put the
question why it does a German Polish
Jews foundations a second only we have
next to the French doesn't get the money
it should get it from the Polish
government or always was a was quite
some retard coming later why are so many
of these important german polish and
institutions without heads on the polish
side without new directors so it's a
question of political well at making
these relations work for the
reconciliation but on the other side i
would agree to all those who say that
german polish reconciliation has been
achieved on the level of people overall
there was i think in the year nineteen
ninety nine a big international
conference in stockholm were people from
Germany and Poland were invited to
present German Poland as an example of
reconciliation I really do hope that
nothing should be done really to to turn
the clock back so when we come to our
topic the place in way one last point
being here in New York in the United
States I would call on everybody to be
more American we have president
Chancellor which are all very close to
President Bush looking very much the
United States what do I mean be more
American the past cannot be the only
point of reference for our political
action if you look to what how how
political action is formed in the United
States it's not the past maybe sometimes
it would be best better to look a bit
into the past but it is the political
will what do I want to achieve and I
think this is actually in the sense as
Marco husky put it should also be an
hour aim to think what do we want to
achieve germs and oppose politically the
place in Europe the place in Europe I
think it's quite clear Germany and
Poland are in the center of Europe this
is not only a geographical positioning
it's also a public political one and the
whole
the European project is largely
dependent on a successful convergence of
poland and germany and the respective
interests and this in my view also means
it would be good if bilateral relations
would be kept out of domestic politics
or arguments used against Europe in that
respect both Poland and Germany are
crucial for the future of Europe and in
that sense starting enlargement shared a
particular historic responsibility and
together they have great influence I
think also on Europe's place in the
world all of European books for politics
shown that skeptics those who always try
to slow your politics in Europe have had
no influence if you would read what
British diplomat said at the signing of
the Treaty of Rome it really nowadays
makes one laugh but we all know that the
motor so-called German French motor of
Europe is not sufficient anymore in
promoting the European project a lot of
people in German had hoped that Poland
would take part in this project but so
far it has not come so far partly i
would say because of the fixation in
poland on this problem so-called problem
of as symmetry a word i hate insurance
relations Germany has no symmetric
relations with any country and I don't
know if there are symmetric relations
and in the world essential in in the
European Union is not really how big you
are but the role you play i would say
luxembourg even though it's a minuscule
country has always played an important
role in the european integration process
and Germany itself I would say has
always been a mover in and an important
promoter of the European idea in a
certain way it has been a part of German
basil dead and it will be and the
question was we have why do people like
Arabic and others questioned if ski have
such an important role and German
politics it is simply because for us the
European project is in the centre of
politics and these people inside Poland
have been European movers and it's not
the question of their individual
relationship to the past which is on the
forefront of German thinking and I think
it's important also for people in Poland
looking to see to see that the
commitment to the EU lies at the core of
German politics and I do hope that
Poland will become more and more one of
the movers which promote in advance the
European Union and the European idea
marchi Trotsky said and I would try to
speak about some of the topics he raised
vision of European integration he said
your enlargement is a beginning and in a
certain way it is and I support this it
is today essential that we make the
integration of
member states into the European Union
work we should not underestimate the
strange that this admission has put on
the European Union and of course it also
raises a question of numbers and
leadership as it was put formerly was
said well nay toe nay toe is a clear
thing NATO there's one shareholder was
51-percent that's the United States in
Europe we have no shareholder was 51%
and also Germany now has only the
presidency and has not the leadership
and doesn't aspire the leadership but
what we need is a structure which makes
it possible to achieve things possible
as we say cursed items fake ID in
relationship to fend off a cat it must
be easier to achieve things and not only
to make things not happen which is
always very easy in such a big
organizations and that is why we need
the still so-called constitutional
treaty I think it's very important that
we have the pradhan declaration which
was supported by the 27 member states
and fixing a deadline to come to a sort
of new basis of our functioning of our
structural functioning and making the
integration successful and here i simply
would say that the way counting was
inside the european union through the
treaty of Nitza will no longer be there
is a complete majority inside European
union which agree that this is no way I
would say it's a is dead another point
you raised was Russia this is really a
big difficult problem here again we have
to talk to geography it is the European
Union's most important neighbor and we
and here I would agree with some of the
points made during the day the Union
Europe European countries European Union
is going through a learning process but
this process is underway and of course
we have to learn that every one of the
Baltic States has its own history was
Russia and this that this one individual
history is more important for Latvia or
Estonia than some of the ideas maybe the
Western European countries have
conceived during the last 40 years or 50
years and I am absolutely confident that
European solidarity will prevail Germany
of course isn't a special situation is
that has good contacts with Russia it
sees the importance of Russia like most
of the rest of Europe especially east
and central europe it needs also a
Russian gas and oil this will continue
for certain while but I am absolutely
sure that everything which is being done
in relationship to Russia is done
through policy of the European Union
because this is the way it simply
functions
the national policies in that respect
don't don't work anymore and of course
now Estonia is a good case and it simply
will be to the detriment of Russia now
in my view I will come to the end and
make two final points I think Europe
needs to be further consolidated on the
international stage there are so many
areas in this world with each ask for a
closer European involvement and I think
transplant know Merkel has shown that
this can be fruitful and useful and that
it is important that the European Union
plays a role like the quartet when it
comes to near East questions last point
I would also say that we need a very
closer integrated Europe as a partner to
the United States it's not only like
Poland Germany having close values close
interests of common nature with the
United States but I also have to say
that in the time when some people were
speaking of old europe new Europe never
were really the interests on the world
scale of if you look at the functioning
of international arena Poland and
Germany further apart the moment
and the United States when it comes to
the role of the United Nations when it
comes to the International Court of
Justice when it comes to questions more
of human rights and so on there are
there is so there is so fundamental a
fundamental closeness i would say
between germany and poland that we have
an interest that this European Union
comes as an actor into the world arena
we Poland and Germany cannot in my view
have an interest in a multilateralism
Alec aft or in other new different
coalition's of the Willing both of us
are interested at something which was
called the West in the old days stays
the West is a community of the United
States was a European nations best sort
of put into an organization through NATO
thank you very much
yes good evening ladies and gentlemen
this is always this thought our destiny
of one of the last speakers that has to
do anything double somersault in front
of you so to keep your attention now in
addition to that my ability of speaking
is very limited can imagine that four
hours ago when having a very nice Greek
salad in one of the Greek restaurants at
murray hill i broke my tooth from the ad
pitted always despite assurances of the
wager that the olives have been careful
repeated so probably I have to apply for
the new directive of the european
commission that the right after we
finish improvement of resulting de ganas
people probably should engage ourselves
into the process of correct fitting
olives in greece I'm sorry but the half
of my face is will be frozen and I have
some difficulties
expression i'm also a humble counselor
servant i do not participate in policy
shaping process in poland and in
addition to that my expertise in polish
german relations which you probably
expect to be demonstrated to a certain
degree is not to be from the past 20
years of my life also professional like
15 I spend on this continent working
location flat Los Angeles Vancouver in
Canada and now somehow crowning of Miami
North American transyl career here in
New York so instead of touching
the world of great politics which has
been dominating over this auditorium for
the past well nine hours now I would
rather offer you that brief confession
of mine based on something what I define
as my understanding of my comprehension
of open society culture and also I'd
like to say just a very few words a few
micro remarks emerging from the
grassroots perspective my impression
after and I spent almost five hours in
the Sun today is that somehow we missed
the perspective
of the ordinary people in Europe
especially in New
in the countries which are new members
of the e u-- i haven't traveled me the
latest results of the public opinion
poll the founding pollen few weeks ago
showing that the support for the public
membership in the EU is still highest in
europe and at the beginning of april was
close to seventy percent in addition to
that another twenty percent because
signs of people in Poland
take it for granted saying that it's
neither nor nor bad so it means that if
something which is as natural for that
mass of water and air so it means that
out of the ten people in common nine in
fact supports our membership and feels
benefits coming from there I mentioning
the speaker because for me it's a very
important figure very important free
assumption on which I think many trans
and processes in shaping for policies
should be should be best i would like to
also to express to you might get
convicted the conviction that we have to
we must not forget about the constant
presence of something which are called
priest is me romantic and historical
dimension of European integration in the
public discourse on multilateral and
also bilateral
the worlds of the apartment and Germany
I see clear in your team between the
overwhelming support in comment of our
membership and
reshaping or redesigning in under these
new circumstances our relations with
several countries with Germany number 1
i'm also also private as a person as a
citizen a little bit photography
over-saturation the present situation
with with history too many details maybe
of course the discussion is is needed
them has to be ongoing especially when
our mutual history is so reaching had
had so many painful moments but sober
looking into the past i think should be
seen mostly and mainly through the prism
of the benefits for the future the
eyewitness war generation is living the
same right in front of our eyes in 1945
my mom was 18 years old two months ago
we celebrated in the city of crack of
her 80th birthday so it means that
certain circle of the post-war history
for the islands generation is almost
closed has been concluded and it also
means that quiet zone will have to deal
solid with the substance of history so i
think that it is our duty to summarize
it and shape it shave the historian s
and i like to turn from computer
language user friendly with the decent
balance of the past understood not as a
burden which for decades characterized
any discussion about polish journal
relations but as an unavoidable
experience of nations which have been
instantly given a miraculous chance
unprecedented in history this is why i
strongly opposed and we didn't reject
attractive but maybe only the first
glance bomb on expression
future author of the early nineteen
ninety-four German reconciliation
amazingly this criticism originated the
younger intellectual formation of many
public figures in Poland and scholars an
i have an impression that they simply
take a current landscape of europe for
granted I'm sorry but fresh and virgin
flavor of freedom and hope at the time
of the berlin wall falling cannot be
replaced by anything else that eruption
of enthusiasm and so to say political
happiness was a rudimentary consequence
of the big history in the making and has
been closed forever within its own
profound uniqueness rayveness healing
the wounds of history needs enormous
courage of vision I think almost 30
years ago I was sitting in the Chicago
radios too young I used to be a college
anywhere at the time as one of the
panelists of the than one of the most
popular political
radio talk show in America i think it
was Steve duesenberg show by popular at
that time there was a TV set in the
studio with live broadcast from Berlin
we talk about what today is called the
the ottoman or nations seated next to me
was one of the American political
scientists professionally oriented
towards Eastern Europe just the previous
day he had arrived from Bucharest as we
were watching cheering crowds under the
Brandenburg Gate listen to the hammering
of the wall this electrologist said with
deep sorrow that Romania is years behind
and there is not a single chance for a
change in a foreseeable future less than
three months later Ceausescu and his
tyranny was toppled so let us not forget
that the vision needs courage I think
the division of Europe so did you find
the wonderful gift of history needs
courage and maybe even at least 180
degrees perspective it not 360 it needs
openness and empathy so if I said at the
beginning to them trying to express my
own personal
kind of old to joy let me call myself
that I feel proud to be the xetonian of
the new on Europe I many many of my
friends feel very comfortable with it
and this is what we have been repeatedly
telling our children so you are trust
confidence building comp our solidarity
diversity I know it sounds like a slow
but it is not adding a pinch of
romanticism to the real political heart
believe that this time history will not
repeat because we have contained in
within its own self this I think draws
an outline of a general message that we
go to the upcoming generations miss Goff
cracovia I live permanently
in beautiful action seafield cracker but
at the same time I feel a little bit
like ich bin ein Berliner thank you
ladies ladies and gentlemen I also want
to heartily bank for the invitation here
to Columbia University and very glad to
be here but as the hands of general
Poland said he was the four leaf almost
the last one I'm the very last one to
speak here and I try to make it short I
would like to first outline some
problems evolving or concerning the
general development of the European
Europe European Union the European
institutions and then in the second part
deal with what I have been able to
observe from Warsaw the importance of
soft topics in not only polish German
but also in general European relations
concerning especially or the eastern
part of Europe a no other state was
after nineteen ninety so vividly
interested in integrating Poland into
the political military and
socio-economic cooperative structures of
the West has had been Germany and this
for good reasons the old federal
republic had been surrounded in the
north the west and the south by
neighbors with
reliable foreseeable relationships had
been established a fact which is
important not only for security reasons
but also because Germany is highly
dependent on export and a stable
framework is necessary for foreign trade
after nineteen ninety so that their fork
Germany supported Poland's intentions
and poland's plans to become a member of
the Western community as much as
possible poland on the other hand was
trying to safeguard its independence
from the soviet union and later russia
by becoming just an integral part of the
political west to which the country had
been belonging since centuries by its
history and culture being put far to the
west geographically in 1945 poland was
paradoxically at the same time put far
east words politically it was solidarity
which in 1989 largely contributed to the
fall of the Soviet system in
east-central europe and the most
reliable partner for gradual integration
into the Western community was united
Germany already in 1990 that slogan of
the German Polish community of interests
and values was formulated which proved
to be true through all the 1990s the
main strategic aims Poland's accession
to NATO and European Union were achieved
until 2004 but now it is not clear which
role the European Union is to play in
the years to come what is the finality
of the year
p and union we have had the last
discussion last large discussion about
this after yashka fishes speech at the
humble university in berlin in two
thousand but it looks as if the great
narrative always larger always tighter
has come to an end the EU is now or has
been in the concept of Schroeder Fisher
rather thought to a guarantee order on
the European continent and was to be
developed to a global player on the
basis of democracy law and liberty
remark there has been remarkable
remarkable progress in the result of the
constitutional process eU foreign
minister extension of majority decisions
more parliamentary zation and so on but
still homogeneous voting in essential
domains remains necessary as in foreign
policy in taxes and so on what seems to
be a situation at the moment is we don't
have a grand design all everybody seems
to limit it sell himself at the moment
to a policy which is feasible new tasks
have arisen and as for instance with the
eg as a geostrategic factor and this
determines for instance the role which
turkey as is being given in the in the
situation in which we renounce at a
deepening of the community it is
interesting to get partners which may
stabilize the geopolitical situation
such as turkey but in the moment when
you want to deepen of the integration
process this question looks different we
do not know until the end which is the
position of the Polish government in
this domain and here in the room are
persons who are much more familiar with
the Polish plans in this dimension in
this direction as what I can could hear
say but i would give some data on the
attitudes of polish into german
population concerning the integration
process a little bit developing a little
bit further what are the council general
it just has said indeed recent data show
that the effect the membership of poland
in the european union is vividly
supported by polish society and here an
important role plays the positive
experience Poland has made especially
with millions of billions of euros
coming from Brussels but it's not only
this the interesting data were taken
some two years ago which show that there
is a high willingness in both societies
to transfer important competences from
the national levels to Brussels because
people expect these problems to be
handled more efficiently on the you
level the topic for items are mentioned
in the same priority and with about the
same percentage in both societies
fighting against international terrorism
87 or eighty-six percent respectively so
in extremely high score fighting against
trafficking with men or rather women
fighting against organized crime and
fighting against drugs between seventy
and eighty percent of poles and Germans
support a foreign a common foreign
defence and security policy more than
sixty percent on both sides are pleading
for a EU Minister of Foreign Affairs
eighty-four percent of the Germans and
71 percent of the poles are supporting a
foreign policy independent from the USA
on the other hand forty-seven percent of
the Germans and fifty-five percent of
the pills want to maintain their
possible the possibility of a veto in
questions of primordial national
interest the conclusion one can draw
from a high tendency of transferring
competences to Brussels on the one side
and to keep national veto powers on the
other is that implicitly a majority of
poles as well as of Germans prefer a
network of intergovernmental cooperation
not a cooperation within the structures
of the super-state many of the
differences between German and polish
elites according to my observation are
caused by misperceptions of the other
side sometimes one has the impression
that a social psychologist sometimes
needed in
german polish relations some of the
these mr Shapps the perceptions have
already been evoke on this conference
let me just give another example
connected with a famous pipeline it's on
the other in the other hand one could
say it's realpolitik where there's
thinking in historical categories a pole
the German politicians of apparels are
looking at energy politic LNG politics
primarily under the prisoner of
political strategic perspectives German
politics or politicians take of a
starting point for planning the existing
political framework in which Poland is
in an institute integral institutional
part of the West at least as a part of
polish politicians is seemed to perceive
problems rather interns of historical
conflicts so the pipeline was perceived
as f Poland was still somewhere in
between Germany and Russia and not part
of the west of the political West this
led to the famous comparison of the
pipeline agreement with the pact
Ribbentrop Molotov the plans of building
this pipeline had long been known I had
even read in the Pope in Polish
newspapers a couple of years before but
the Poland had reacted upon these plans
only in the final phases and according
to my knowledge the pipeline is not of
vital interest for Poland's energy
supply but the circumstances it became
known to the larger public where
catastrophic
the president hula was in lines at the
University fifth anniversary of pole of
solidarity s founding and there he said
we are friends now partners in the
European Union and we are I have a
permanent dialogue and nothing that will
be important for Poland will be decided
above the heads of the Paris exactly one
week later polish public opinion was
informed by the media that the authority
on the pipeline was signed and there
were spectacular pictures of Putin and
joy de as the grandfathers of these as
the grant was a god are the gods flowers
at the godfathers of these a treaty
which was for the poles for me it was
clear what the erections in Poland will
be and one must say there is in wasn't a
striking lack of historical sensibility
on the German side in the future in my
opinion soft topics will have an
important impact upon the relations
between countries like Poland and
Germany but also between Poland and her
eastern neighbors with what is necessary
that is a building confidence building
confidence between societies which had
been have been divided by the Iron
Curtain or on the other side in under
Soviet aside where had been pressure
from the Soviet side not to discuss
critical problems and this demands
spectacular everyday work on the liver
on the level of civil societies we must
better not we must better know each
other we have to discuss about conflicts
between our societies in the part of the
former Soviet block of south conflicts
originating from the Second World War or
even from the time before these
difficulties or these problems had been
frozen and I have come to the outside
very vividly after 1989 the most tragic
tragic example was Yugoslavia there are
there have been very positive examples
on the german-polish side for instance
on the commission of school books which
has this because since 35 years
discussed at the beginning under
sometimes very difficult circumstances
die lateral relations in history and
what has has been gained in the course
of the years and now we have a change of
the generations this is really
confidence between us we are partners
now we trust each other and this is
something you can't decree from above
German
jenny has found it his Historical
Institute in warsaw in 1993 in order to
better research our polish history we
know that our knowledge on polish
history is limited we are very glad that
last year in a an institute a policy
institute of the similar type has been
found it in berlin and we have to
integrate now that you're a Europe isn't
divided any longer we must integrate
also in this concerns especially the
rest the West we have to integrate parts
of the history of the eastern part of
Europe also into our history for
instance it is remarkable in the
European context in comparative
perspective that given a proportion of
the SH laughter where is the gentry of
six to ten percent of the population
already since the 16th century early
forms of general franchise developed in
a degree from which for instance England
at the beginning of the 19th century was
far away little is known in Western
Europe that in the development of human
and civil rights in you any European
perspective the Magna Charta had a
Polish equivalent in the Constitution of
naming him captiva vemos of 1434 or that
the Constitution niall navi of 15-5 in
which Parliament got the Kings agreement
that nothing that concerns Parliament
could be introduced without its consent
anticipated aims of the glorious
revolution in England and of the
American
Lucien of 1776 we have moreover we
should look that there have been has
been a lot of positive examples of
cooperation between poles enjoyments in
the now West a Polish West in torrey
territories the former German
territories and a striking example for
me are the towns of gains and Virat Slav
Vlad Slava is exposing its multicultural
heritage when it celebrated its
millennium of the thousand years of the
diocese of God's love it invited to
British historians Norman Davies and
Roger Moore house to write the history
of this town a German historian Cairo
tomb wrote a book pick a very big book
on how the German Breslau became the
Polish Virat suave and this book has
been translated into polish now and the
city office of Rod suave is promoting
this book because it presents not only
an interdisciplinary approach but also
shows not only the problems of the
German population but also which problem
for instance the Polish administration
had to implement polish administration
in the town after 1945 this is a very
interesting approach and one of our
fellows is writing the PhD dissertation
at the no visas at the moment on how the
Polish town of garage naw became a white
brelo yellow
in town and I hope the people of Virat
slav will experience a same book on roof
and reef when I had a just another
example okay I I see it's a but we would
have we could mention quite a lot of
these things just one thing because
operation between the universities is
Oprah gives one a wonderful result more
and more German students are studying in
Poland last year's the number was more
than a thousand and three hundred and
these people become it it is supported
by the Erasmus programme of the EU in
which the credit points achieved here
are acknowledged at home so the students
don't lose time come here to Poland and
I'm sorry I'm in what I'm warsaw-based
which you see come to Poland and they
get to know thinkers is very important
in the long run because we we are
partners now and not looking to only to
the West but also to the east and
they're saying i hope that Germans will
much more deal in the future with Poland
with a Czech Republic with these people
but also that poles will deal with
Ukrainians yellow Russians and the and
so on here we can create confidence in
the long run and it is very interesting
to see a
I just one minute to see the results of
an empirical research public are
published last year after the troubles
in German Polish relations one could
have expected that people see the
german-polish relations much worse then
say in the year 2000 the opposite is
true the peop people see polish
relations on both sides better than five
years before and why because they have
everyday contact on very on a lot of
levels and this is what I propose also
for Poland and Germany towards their
Eastern neighbors to increase these
contacts on social sciences sometimes
there is discussion what is more
important structures or actors political
actors here we can say let's create the
structures let's create gradually
structures with which create a climate
in which wise political actors and the
given moment will be able to a deal and
to make use of the situation which is
then quite natural in the same way as it
was after 1989 natural that the now
members of the European Union will join
the West political West thank
tired but I hope we have time for short
questions 15 minutes made with
discussion thank you very much once more
congratulations for the last panelist it
was really inspiring and if you let me I
would like to make two comments first
comment is on the current polish
engagement into the EU policy and the
second one is just regards the future so
i would like to start with just taking
that a very basic factor which was
supported by the data provided us by the
professor that in Europe there is no
more nation which seems its interests as
much connected to the European process
as the Polish nation and it is a
caesarean you can I guess you can you
can agree with me it is deeply rooted in
our heritage in our historical
experiences as a matter of fact Poland
and its eastern or central Eastern
European history always was looking for
cooperation for creation stronger
institutions like for example polish to
any in union which was one of the most
successful unions of this kind in europe
and also it is based in the experience
of both total charities now i would like
to say that sometimes it's better to
look
facts then not only to concentrate on
the climate of the public discussion or
what is red in the in the media because
if you take the concrete's the Pope the
current published engagement into the EU
is my opinion very very high let's
consider the Polish participation in
writing of the Berlin declaration it is
not only the German services it is also
the Polish such success then let's
consider our engagement in writing of
the energy declaration from the last
European summit in March I do believe
that our engagement was the crucial also
to convince some other European partners
in the general European position let's
say let's consider our position vis a
vie European Union policy towards Russia
that during the one of the last workers
are representative agreed with you can
commissioned a very exact moves as a
matter of fact supporting the the
committee is a commission by not making
any kind of remarks to the proposal of
the negotiation mandate for the with
Russia could you find the opposite
examples I cannot so I think that first
of all not let's not concentrate on Miss
let's concentrate on facts then the
future and
the Cuchulain if we are so pro-european
it means also that from our perspective
it would make sense to strengthen
institution institutions in indy you
also to strengthen foreign policy
institutions from our perspective it
would be great to have the position of
European Union foreign ministry and to
have quite strong and effective apparent
use to support European European
influence but if there are some
questions if there are some doubts there
are not because at the Polish government
the whole society is not engaged enough
into the European process we are facing
a very important debate at the moment
may-maybe which had not been enough
formulated or enough structure and I
would like to make a small
simplification so please forgive me but
when during one of the last panels we
discussed the problem of realpolitik and
the political based on values that is
the fundamental question for the whole
European Union foreign policy if it
should be based on the realpolitik or
whether it should be based on village
and that is the difference between
Poland and Germany the Polish history
the Polish foreign policy also from
today is close with strictly based on
values and it is something water in his
very inspiring presentation said mr. God
the problem is the Torah Gavin said that
the problem is that the current support
with the current polish support for
Estonia just comes from the idealistic
based on values believe in the fight for
freedom and all the opposite side when I
asked the question to my German
colleagues what is the role of
realpolitik is in protocol thinking in
Germany and the answer was that there
were two different answers but there was
something what connected that still
realpolitik is very important in shaping
the political ideas also on foreign
policy in German it is contradictory so
if you are talking about the common
foreign policy it can not be based on
real quality to be effective it should
be based on values because the EU is
pasted on village if we base it on the
real quality you are coming back of one
one sentence longer sentence you are
coming back to the 19th century policy
at the U is not about it so we have to
decide and please believe me having the
be convened convinced that we will
create the foreign policy based on
values Poland will be one hundred
percent for it thank you
yeah this is really short joke man I
enjoy very much what America chatzky
said some of his ideas I think we're
right and were wrong they were always
interesting and thoughtful as always but
one really made you laugh that is what
you said about undo on competition for
the Americans favor I mean for years you
have told us and complained about her
thank you Mary and you were right and
now we tell me that you're jealous of
how close under America is to george
bush but i wanted to be very enough
activity yeah we have to go that what do
you react upon involved in please what
to say you're like to say
no question
no what one thing I think because the
title of this conference is
reconciliation and its story I have a
one possible never again to speak about
the Constitution this also you know
probabilities division important
political but it is not division between
people who are four and the games as a
DVD as we can say so and to start to
talk about politics and boys round that
sound about values about about power or
stuff about freedom how we understand
the kingdom because I must say my son
death in the face I live in our so
unless kapatic Europe because I ask
myself how we your be answered
understand political pedo it is not that
partly a kind of integration can be a
danger
three hours of the citizens then the
next and I not agree with Miss Matthews
method German is not interesting not
looking is no it's looking for if you
compare this in the United States up in
this respect I don't agree with my
because you know this competition from
this global perspective you are various
balls and small condoms yeah but the
problem of German is not the lack of
index I think it's a problem United
States lack of a person more in Central
Europe some it said it said no it's a
crate of interest it is you know if you
if you look at this as a nonsense which
is your present in there in the German
army media I Sundance wish there would
be less interesting part in german
lesson yeah but more yeah and the self
remark I when I hear you're an ikea
politician I sometimes ever as average
sociologists have the impression that
day you know they have only nation to
magically use of language to perform i
use of thing which when they say like
mr. handsome you know there's no are
symmetry between pollen capture of
course there is you can say this doesn't
thousand one yeah but they would be yeah
so and i think that the problem today
that is in from the German Pacific you
say the general really have to resync
it's wrong in the Central Europe once
again once again because the new stage
of development this is a new situation
and accept the Sun the channel news
becomes of excellent however I became
totally useless in this new situation
because it is not what we expect from
German as a European partner to be an
object of Sofia ionization Spanish its
exact there was this a consideration so
so this death occurred as new I think
your reflection in African language and
then trying to understand because I
something's maybe cut the impression
missing also unique in different
categories what politics about is what
freedom is what are the dangers what are
the games and I think maybe we share
their values in this very abstract sense
but there is a question of concatenation
of these values according to our crystal
immensity think
thank you for a thousand times I have a
final statement about how to the final
shape of polish German reconciliations
last Saturday week ago my daughter got
married I attended the ceremony French
Jack in Paris and he looks likely moving
to German well unless upbeat note I
wanted to do this conference for a very
long time and now it's behind this I'm
sorry that we did not build in another
panel which could have taken place
tomorrow to have just a general
discussion without any presentations to
discuss these threads that came out
during the various panels that we
couldn't solve today because well
they're probably not solvable but the
worth talking about and I think that
that is the the great part of polish
German relations that comes out of this
discussion this is not Russia and
Estonian this is a civilized discussion
between two countries that have learned
the ropes and are operating within a
system and you can't always agree on
everything but you can certainly talk
about it that's the great lesson of
Europe after the Second World War which
both countries have accepted a
conference like this doesn't happen by
itself there are many people who are
involved we're very grateful to the
critical foundation both for allowing us
to use their facility yesterday as well
as for paying for most of the the costs
of this conference yesterday and today
were very great folks that Polonia
separate penalty foundation
in Warsaw also for supporting the
program we have worked with other
partners here I mentioned earlier
professor krasno demsky for whom this
conference is something of a swan song
because unfortunately his University of
the University of Bremen couldn't get
along without him for another year and
so he is not going to stay with us next
year he's going back to Germany rather
soon and were very sorry about that my
colleague Volker Birkin was sitting
quietly in the back of the room who was
always involved in the planning and
implementation not only of this
conference but all of the conference's
that we do and then of course the staff
of our small center downstairs Kevin
hallinan a Shabbat chick who's waiting
patiently to serve you at the perception
that we're going to have on a chaplain
ska and alina Hasani who all together
worked very hard to make this something
of a success and finally our
videographer coquelin each who is going
to take all of what we've done and make
it look even better so I thank you all i
thank the diplomats for taking valuable
time out of their their days our polish
friends including several high-ranking
advisers to the president which was sort
of discreetly omitted during these
discussions for taking time out of their
long holiday than made third holiday to
come to New York and be with us and our
German friends for also coming to New
York and taking time out of their busy
schedules it was a pleasure to have the
wall here I hope that we can do this
again at some point whether it's here or
in Germany or in Poland Peter Zane the
Virginia Dubrow notes and please join us
for a reception thank you very much
you